تطور ايضا السفيره الامريكيه بالعراق تدين
الهجمات الصاروخيه على كردستان العراق
وهجمات المسيرات على قاعده اربيل الجويه
وقد اعلن مجلس امن اقليم كردستان ان الحرس
الثوري الايراني هجم بصواريخ بالستيه عده
اماكن بمدينه مدينه اربيل وبحسب احصائيه
اوليه قتل اربعه مدنيين واصيب سته اخرون
ورفض المجلس التبرير الايراني بان الغاره
استهدفت مجموعات معارضه لطهران واعتبر
مجلس الامن في كردستان الضربه انتهاكا
لسياده الاقليم والعراق وطالب الحكومه
الاتحاديه والمجتمع الدولي بعدم السكوت
على هذه الجرائم وفق
وصفه وقد اعلن مجلس امن اقليم كردستان ان
الحرس الثوري الايراني هجم بصواريخ
بالستيه عده اماكن مدنيه في اربيل وبحسب
احصائيه اوليه قتل اربعه مدنيين واصيب سته
اخرون ورفض المجلس التبرير الايراني بان
الغاره استهدفت مجموعات معارضه لطهران
واعتبر المجلس ان الضربه هي انتهاك لسياده
الاقليم والعراق وطلب الحكومه الاتحاديه
والمجتمع الدولي بعدم السكوت على هذه
الجرائم وفق
وصفه من بغداد ينضم الينا مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي اذا عامر المزيد فيما يتعلق
بهذا او برد الفعل هذا الذي تم على هذه
الضربه الايرانيه وايضا ينضم الينا من
طهران مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد القادر فايز
سنعود اليك عبد القادر ولكن ابدا معك عامر
لافي اذا و مستوى رد الفعل
العراقي نعم مياده واضح ان هناك غضب شديد
عراقي على ما جرى في اربيل وهذا يبدو
واضحا من خلال البيان بيان وزاره الخارجيه
العراقيه الذي استنكر بشده حسب وصف هذا
البيان ما جرى وقال بانه انتهاك لسياده
العراق وانتهاك لمبدا حسن الجوار وقال بان
المستهدف كانت مساكن مدنيه وان مدنيين
قتلوا ومن بينهم رجل اعمال من اقليم
كردستان رجل اعمال شهير ايضا قتل في هذا
الاستهداف وبالتالي هناك غضب عراقي واضح
كما ذكرنا من هذا البيان لكن ربما الاهم
في ما جاء في بيان وزاره الخارجيه هو
اعتزام بغداد التقدم بشكوى الى مجلس الامن
ل شكايه ايران بسبب هذا الاستهداف وان
رئيس الوزراء العراقي قد امر بتشكيل لجنه
للتحقيق وتقصي الحقائق وجمع الادله لتكون
مسانده للموقف العراقي عندما يتقدم بشكوى
الى مجلس الامن وبالفعل هذه اللجنه قد تم
تشكيلها واعلن عنها وستكون برئاسه مستشار
الامن الوطني العراقي قاسم الاعرجي الذي
بالمناسبه توجه قبل قليل على راس وفد رفيع
الى اربيل للوقوف على التطورات هناك هذه
اللجنه مكونه كما ذكرنا من مستشار الامن
القومي من ايضا وزير داخليه اقليم كردستان
و ووكيل جهاز المخابرات العراقيه وممثلين
عن العمليات المشتركه قياده العمليات
المشتركه ووزاره الدفاع وبالتالي هذه
اللجنه ستقوم بعملها وقالت وزاره الخارجيه
ان نتائج هذا التحقيق سيتم ايضا اطلاع
الشعب العراقي على نتائج هذا التحقيق ايضا
رئيس الجمهوريه مياده استنكر ما جرى وندد
به وقال بان هذا انتهاك صارخ لسياده
العراق وقال بانه يجب حل هذه المسائل
بالتعامل وبالتفاح وليس بالقصف العسكري
خصوصا في هذه الفتره الحرجه التي تشهد
فيها المنطقه توتر كبير طبعا مياده لابد
هنا من الاشاره الى ان اي
ذهاب بغداد الى مجلس الامن وليست المره
الاولى هي شكت ايران قبل ذلك عندما قصفت
انتقاما لمقتل سليماني في عام 2020 عندما
استهدفت قاعده عين الاسد ايضا توجهت الى
مجلس الامن ايضا توجهت ل لشكا الولايات
المتحده في نفس العام عندما استهدف قاسم
سليماني هنا في بغداد لكن تبقى تركيا ربما
هي صاحبه النصيب الاكبر من شكايه العراق
الى مجلس الامن حث حث في كثير من المرات
ربما اخر مره ذهبت وشكت تركيا في حزيران
الماضي 23 وفي اعوام اخرى 22 و205 وفي
الكثير من الاعوام بسبب القصف التركي
المستمر على شمال العراق ا ابقى معنا عامر
و